To walk on the set in front
of hundreds of people and
look good in that suit and you know i take
my hat off to both of them they both trained
so i worked out a bunch i loved the challenge
of it it was harder as a non-mid-20s person to
get into the kind of shape where the spandex isn't
going to show everything up so one piece it's kind
of like he just puts the whole thing it's just
one jumpsuit of course there is so you might see a
weapon that he uses now in this film that he never
had before but it was part of his old technology
we put zippers in a slightly easier position and
it was very funny when they were like talking
to each other each of them was jealous of the
other ones the avengers the avengers what's that
you're killing me
Welcome back everyone this will be my spider-man
no way home deleted scenes video they finally
started dropping some of the deleted scenes
it's funny to watch them not being able to
get through any of those just because they make
each other laugh so much but there's a lot of
really cool deleted scenes here to break down
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos this is just
a fraction of the deleted scenes and the bonus
features they'll be releasing it on a home video
soon and we're doing a giveaway for that too
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite deleted scene from the video
in the comments the other really big news you
may have seen in your feeds this morning is that
william hurt who played thunderbolt ross in the
mcu just passed away like literally just passed
away it's really sad he was an amazing actor
so may he rest in peace but just out of respect
right now i'm probably not going to do a video
about that or anything when we get to she-hulk
episodes and we start talking about what's going
on with all the whole characters i will address
thunderbolt ross during those but it's going to
be a little while before that happens but i will
say careful for spoilers for spider-man no way
home if you have not seen the movie yet i think
there's still a couple people that are waiting to
see the movie but in the video that i put at the
beginning of this you can see a lot of the extra
scenes that they shot with tobey maguire andrew
garfield and all the sinister six characters
like i said it's only a small fraction of the
deleted scenes so when they release it on home
video i will do a bigger deleted scenes video
but the first big thing that you can see that they
filmed was a scene where toby maguire spider-man
fought green goblin on his glider the same way
that andrew garfield fought his villain electro
from amazing spider-man 2 like toby maguire and
andrew garfield each had moments during the big
final fight of the statue of liberty where
their versions of spider-man fought their
villains from their movies in one of the biggest
complaints after the movie there weren't many
complaints because it was a great movie but
one of the things people wished they had done
was have some kind of scene with tobey maguire and
willem defoe's green goblin just to acknowledge
all the history that they have between the
two of them i've been like a father to you
be a son to me now to be fair they did reference
a lot of the green goblins storyline from that
first spider-man movie earlier in the film
when they were all meeting each other inside
doctor strange's prison cells just realizing that
each of them had died in their original universes
without completely understanding it right away
you know i'm something of a scientist myself
it is cool to see that they actually did film
a tobey maguire versus green goblin scene but
for whatever reason it just didn't make the final
cut i'm assuming that's because they were turning
this big statue of liberty fight into an avengers
endgame final battle situation like during end
game the final battle no joke is like 30 minutes
long and i think they didn't want the statue
of liberty fight to go on for that long because
they wanted to get on to the moment where doctor
strange had to weave his second spell where you
see all of reality tearing all around them and the
first spell that they still haven't fixed yet is
bringing all those extra sinister six multiverse
villains to the main mcu earth there were so
many deleted versions of this final battle too
there were versions where they had america chavez
who's going to show up during doctor strange 2
in this final fight but that was when they were
doing spider man no way home before they were
going to release doctor strange multiverse of
madness that happens with all the marvel movies
like really early on when they start boarding
out all these fights and trying to figure out
what the big action scenes are going to be the
special effects people actually have to start on
those before they start actually filming the movie
because they take so long to complete and a lot of
times they'll start working on these big fight
scenes and conceptualizing them before they've
locked down all the characters that are going
to be in the movie so they have to do a bunch
of different versions just depending on what winds
up working out through the actual filming process
but the next big deleted scene is of the sinister
six just being this awkward squad together
like all casual like as if they're not all evil
genius super villains from alternate universes
just me and the boys riding casually in the
elevator if you haven't watched spider-man
2 with tobey maguire in a long time this is very
obviously meant to be a reference to the infamous
elevator scene where spider-man is forced to take
the elevator instead of web slinging away like he
normally would it rides up in the crotch a little
bit too like each of these villains can either fly
transport themselves through power lines jump from
building the building using their many octopus
arms but they're reduced to riding in an elevator
like common people the way they actually cut
this in the film like the jump cut to them just
walking into happy's apartment was a little funny
and i think just because of the comedy of having
them all hang out in the apartment together doctor
octopus commenting on how ridiculous all was
probably felt like enough that's why they probably
got rid of this elevator scene it just felt too
extra but if there's anything that i'd like to see
more of it's just the energy of them interacting
with each other all the sinister six villains like
when they were in the cells it was probably one
of the funniest parts of the film the next big
deleted scene is actually a matt murdock daredevil
deleted scene and it's him defending happy hogan
later in the events of the film and being his
very good lawyer so to speak in this board room
like he told happy hogan you're going to need
a very good lawyer because damage control is
definitely gonna sue you let's see what he has to
say matt you're gonna need a really good lawyer
how did you just do that i'm a really good lawyer
these people in the boardroom that are grilling
the two of them are the damage control lawyers and
they're suing happy for stealing the stark tech
even though if you think about it it's weird for
damage control department of the government to
sue happy when the stark tech actually belongs to
stark industries so pepper potts could always say
oh you know it's happy please don't sue him just
bring the tech back they did actually film a scene
with a young version of morgan stark from avengers
end game obviously she's a couple years older at
this point but she was going to be in the film as
part of all these scenes with them grilling happy
about the stolen stark tech there is a much longer
version of this matt murdock daredevil deleted
scene i'll do a video for that when they release
it officially she might wind up showing up later
in this scene and if it wasn't clear happy would
have had to stolen iron man's arc reactor in the
3d printer before all the stuff with mysterio's
video went down and j jonah jameson started his
spider man broadcast so somewhere in the aftermath
of their big fight with mysterio happy coming back
to his apartment and things sort of settling for
a brief hot second before mysterio's video happy
would have taken this extra arc reactor in the
3d printer to his apartment the old 3d printer
that he had during spider man far from home that
they used to make the advanced suit on the jet got
blown up by mysterio and if he didn't spot it
the arc reactor that he stole is the iron man
mark vi reactor that he created at the
end of iron man 2 with the new element
and then used again during the avengers movie
there were also a lot of references with the arc
reactor and doctor octopus's fusion reactor and if
you don't remember doctor octopus crushed the arc
reactor during the big final fight destroying
it the power of the sun the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand it looks like there are
a bunch of other deleted scenes with each of the
sinister six films during this final fight they
filmed so much extra footage for all these fights
at the statue of liberty and just whittled it down
to the essentials for this theatrical version they
talk a lot about how they upgraded toby maguire
and andrew garfield's spider-man suits from their
movie with the modern materials and enhancements
just to make them more practical to actually walk
around in all day while they were filming same
thing for willem dafoe's green goblin armor it's
crazy how important zippers are for these super
suits like back in the day 20 plus years ago they
didn't have zippers like this so they were just
way more uncomfortable to wear which is why the
costume department is saying that each of them
toby maguire andrew garfield tom holland were
jealous of each other's suits tom holland actually
said that toby mcguire and andrew garfield's suits
were both way more comfortable to wear than his
mcu spider-man suits i think that's mostly because
toby and andrew's suits are much more cloth-based
way more lo-fi which is what he does with the
brand new spider-man suit at the end of the movie
the whole idea with that suit is that it's meant
to look much more like toby's and andrew's suits
he was inspired by their suits after spending so
much time with them that's why his new spider-man
symbol even though the whole suit the spider-man
symbol looks more comic book accurate looks much
more like andrew garfield's and toby mcguire's
spider-man symbol and their suits but if it
wasn't clear even though it is like the comic
book friendly neighborhood spider-man version
of the suit now much more comic book accurate
he did cannibalize some parts from the old
advanced suit to make it that's why you see
some of the scraps from the advanced suit like the
mask itself i think is still mostly the mask from
the advanced suit so the irises for the eyes will
still work the same way speaking of matt murdock
daredevil in marvel phase four it'll be the
same thing for him when he comes back as full-on
daredevil like they'll give him a new costume
that'll be a little bit more comic book accurate
but also using modern materials so it's just much
more comfortable for charlie cox to walk around in
all day when he's filming there's a bunch of big
marvel stuff happening the moon knight episodes
are going to be starting in a couple weeks i'll
do videos for all of them just like i do for all
the other marvel disney plus series so if you
have any questions or big video requests just
leave them in the comments below and i'll name a
giveaway winner when i do my next big marvel video
everyone click here for that brand new boys season
3 trailer video with jensen ackles it's a big
parody of justice league dc and marvel characters
and click here for my brand new star wars obi-wan
kenobi trailer video and a first look at hayden
christensen's darth vader during that series
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!